[Applause]
hi dr. Peterson now I've been wanting to
ask you this for a while now since I
started watching your lectures after I
started reading and Nicci's Beyond Good
and Evil
I came upon a paragraph in his chapter
on scholars that really really bothered
me and it actually bothers me to this
day he talked about this kind of person
like they were just a mirror-like they
stretched he said every part of their
skin basically to allow every new piece
of information that they took on and
that all they ever were was just an
instrument they were just a mirror on
reflecting what they had learned never
actually having generated anything on
their own and it's it's bothered me
because I feel like in a way it's sort
of like it's it's it's impacted my
identity a lot because I don't know how
are you supposed to create something you
know
okay well that's okay that that's a
really good question I mean Nietzsche is
often classed with the existentialists
right and so one of the tenants of
existentialist there's two real tenants
of existentialism there's more but
obviously we're oversimplifying but one
is that life is a problem it isn't
because there's something wrong with you
it's that life is a problem and so
that's often contrasted with the
Freudian view which is that if you have
a problem it's because something went
wrong during your development the
existentialist said no no it's like life
is a problem make no mistake about it
and that
the purpose of the purpose of
scholarship is in some sense to solve
that problem and so for Nietzsche like
he said all truths are bloody truth to
me and what he meant by that was that if
an idea didn't incarnate itself in you
and transform your perceptions and your
actions then you were merely possessed
by the idea you were merely a
spokesperson for the idea or you could
say that the idea possessed you you're a
puppet for the idea it's not you it's
the idea is in you and it has you you
haven't taken the idea and incorporated
with you and made it part of your life
and so there's a romanticism that's
associated with that right that's the
passionate scholar the person for whom
ideas are not merely they're not merely
what would you call abstracted
representations that can be tossed about
as if they're commodities they're
they're they're more like pert they're
more like personalities that might be
another way of thinking about it and so
if you're if if those ideas are
compelling then you don't like one thing
I learned a long time ago and I think
this is probably relevant I know when I
was a kid I liked to argue and I liked
to win arguments or or or lose them
although I liked winning them a lot
better but I didn't really mind so much
what the content of the argument was you
know I could engage in it like a
sparring match and it was in some sense
to establish dominance right to
establish intellectual dominance I quit
doing that when I was in my mid-20s
because I thought that that was too
shallow an approach to the ideas they
they're not commodities of that sort
they're there they have tendrils that
reach down into the living that's the
right way to think about it and so
Nietzsche's criticism of scholars and he
did this a lot was that they were
bloodless you know they didn't they were
full of performative contradictions
that's another way of thinking about
they'd say one thing and do another
because their intellect was completely
dissociated from
they're from their actions and Heath he
he thought that was a very bad idea
and I think that that's a good criticism
I think it is a bad idea I also think it
makes for an extraordinarily boring
lecturer you know because you can tell
if you're listening to someone whether
the ideas that you're hearing are merely
being passed through the person as if
they're being memorized say or whether
they're part of the dynamic core of the
person and if they're part of the
dynamic core of the person then they're
almost always engaging and gripping and
so he wasn't a fan of bloodless scholars
and I think that's correct because one
of the things that I see it's not a good
idea to have ideas possess you unless
you know what the ideas are up to and
lots of people are possessed by ideas
rather than possessing them and that
what that means is they haven't taken
the ideas and integrated them into their
own being
they haven't it's like an incarnation in
a sense they haven't incarnated the
ideas in in embodied form and so they're
incomplete
you know Nietzsche also in thus spake
Zarathustra when 0th Easter comes down
the mountain he sees a bunch of people
gathered around a famous individual I
think maybe a scholar but it doesn't
really matter and when 0th Easter goes
in looks at the person all he sees his
little tiny midget with a gigantic ear
and so he's a hyper specialist right and
so he has a pretty impressive year but
he's only this big and that was
Nietzsche's imagistic commentary on the
danger of hyperspecialization
and also on the danger of adulation for
hyperspecialization
and and because he thought about it as a
kind of deformity
now Nietzsche was a pretty harsh guy but
but he did address the issue of the
relationship between intellectual
knowledge and and action because for
Nietzsche
those things are not to be separated in
some sense so yes so maybe I don't know
why it maybe it bothered you like it's
hard to say why I bothered you it might
have bothered you because it's sort of
undermined the idea of scholar but the
other possibility and this isn't an
accusation because
obviously I don't know anything about
you but it might also be that it struck
a chord you know and that maybe you were
doubtful or questioning how tightly
associated your intellectual endeavor
was with your actual character and your
practice so that's another possibility I
mean that's a really good thing to think
about because generally speaking that
integration is it is very much lacking
people are a lot smarter and fluid with
their ideas than they are ethical and
consistent and characterized by
integrity so yep
[Applause]